[Applaudissements]
david saint jacques est en pleine forme
rien à voir avec l'astronaute qui est
sorti de la capsule soyouz le 24 juin
incommodé par la gravité
en 17 jours sa réadaptation est
impressionnante
il fait la fierté des employés de
l'agencé spatiale canadienne
il n'a pas encore la permission de faire
du vélo mais a retrouvé le droit de
conduire la gravité lui joue parfois des
tours lorsqu'il ferme les yeux de deux à
six mois avant d'être complètement
fonctionnel encore donc on est comme mon
retour parce que c'est faux travail sur
eux pour deux ou trois semaines
le suivi serré de son état de santé
permet de compléter des expériences
scientifiques dans l'espace ces
problèmes-là se développe très vite j'ai
déjà par ailleurs en excellente santé
donc c'est ce qu'on est comme les
cobayes parfait pour la recherche
médicale
non seulement il vient de loin mais il
était parti depuis longtemps
pour le ministre n'avait dbase david
saint jacques est un héros national
un exemple pour le programme spatial
canadien qui doit préparer la relève
combien d'enseignants ont préparé à toi
mission au cours de sa mission
l'astronaute canadien a parlé 20 fois à
des jeunes
le question c'est est ce que la station
spatiale internationale
et comme une maison wima health et ses
bonnes questions mais c'est une drôle de
maison c'est comme stressant ta maison
pendant six mois tu pas d'or mais enfin
je vais devoir une fois pour les enfants
du camp de jour de l'école nationale
d'aérotechnique il a démontré à quel
point la capsule soyouz est exigu il
faut tellement proches que nous oppose
se touchent comme ça on est comme ça
comme ça comme ça on a les genoux pliés
pisser dessus on a plein de bagages
on peut même pas se voir les uns les
autres on est collé comme ça je n'en
peux plus voir les mains des uns des
autres
c'est ça du travail d'équipé les blues
n'ont pas j'ai eu la chance d'accomplir
tout ce que je pouvais rêver accomplir
là haut pour ce grand communicateur un
ego portrait avec l'assistance et une
photo de gros puis il est sorti de côté
tout simplement
lui qui depuis six mois terminées ces
échanges en profitant de la pesanteur
pour épater les jeunes ici à nous
despatie radio canada longueuil